les seuls qui sont là parce qu'ils sont
bonnes c'est nous deux invités de ce
soir parce que je voudrais vous parler
d'un coup de cœur un film j'ai vraiment
un coup de cœur là-dessus je reçois
assez erzy que j'adore ça avant c'était
rencontré dans la rue un jour on a eu un
tu vois c'est bien entendu voilà c'est
vrai et alors oui je j'ai eu un coup de
cœur aussi pour toi Steve vraiment
incroyable dans le film j'ai plein de
potes qui m'écrivent sur ce film aussi
et qui me disent que c'est vraiment le
film qu'il faut aller voir c'est sorti
aujourd'hui au cinéma ça fait d'ailleurs
un très bon démarrage oui ou pas comme
quoi je commence à avoir du plaisir dans
le cinéma parce que je vous rappelle
pour la petite anecdote j'avais refusé
de jouer dans qu'est-ce qu'on a fait au
bon Dieu je le sens pas voilà pour vous
dire j'avais du pif à l'époque regardez
on va regarder la bande-annonce c'est
parti
un alignement de Planète parfait et
c'est en ça que c'est inédit pourquoi tu
t'en vas déjà là
l'autre Christophe il est sorti du
placard il est revenu dans le coin sur
tes petites inventions là faut pas qu'il
reste ici il va nous dans la
merde avec les renards
sans vous adapter soit vous disparaissez
Rudy son taf c'est de cacher les sous
près ne dispaction nourrice vous avez
fait quoi de votre argent
à part baiser des poser des
détails et faire des locks hein
[Musique]
les petits vont tuer une fixette sur toi
et ton frère ils disent que vous niquez
l'équipe de la cité après cet alignement
le nom ne sera plus jamais mec
S
merci d'être avec la d'être avec nous
merci alors qu'il a vu comment le film
très bien vous avez vu c'est rare que
autant de gens voient le film les chéris
les gens merci d'être là si c'est un tes
premiers plateaux c'est mon premier
plateau
c'est le deuxième je l'ai déjà fait
[Applaudissements]
dans je pense il y a très peu de
scénarios qui vont se faire sans toi je
te le jure tu es un coup de coeur
incroyable je pense tu vas être je te
dis tu vas tu vas tu vas tout déchirer
merci et déjà c'est déjà le cas mais ça
va être encore plus haut tu verras je te
l'aurais dit et je ressortirai cette
image au moins je pourrais la vendre
assez cher
c'est important oui moi j'ai adoré le
film je ne suis pas ennuyé une seconde
et ce qui m'a marqué c'est que
contrairement à d'autres films qui se
passent dans les quartiers j'ai
découvert que en fait c'était les petits
qui faisaient la loi que les grands
comme vous il y a un moment si vous
prenez un coup de pression par un mec
qui est presque mineur est-ce que c'est
une réalité ça ou c'est une image dans
le film en fait c'est une réalité c'est
un film qui parle de c'est le c'est un
choc des cultures entre les anciens et
la nouvelle génération qui qui veut
s'installer qui veut prendre sa place
parce que les anciens ont une manière de
penser qu'il ne va plus aux jeunes et
les anciens n'êtes plus légers
donc les jeunes ils se rebellent donc il
y a souvent des coups de pression comme
ça
oui c'est un film incroyable parce que
il a une puissance qui vous c'est un
film qui a la rage partout alors il y a
plein et il y a plein de gens il y a la
science-fiction il y a le côté suspense
chronique sociale voilà social on est
dans les cités aussi et moi ce que je
voulais vous demander c'est face à tous
ces genres incroyables notamment vous
after vous êtes en quelque sorte le
point d'équilibre on a l'impression que
tout tourne subtilement autour de vous
est-ce que vous lavez ressenti dans le
film à la lecture des scénario oui parce
que mon personnage c'est la seule femme
du film et c'est celle qui prend la
décision de partir qui est déterminée à
quitter la cité avec son enfant et
souvent dans dans les cités c'est les
femmes qui
qui dirigent tout quoi la famille les
enfants et
qui veulent s'en enfin et qui veulent
partir
oui c'est un film fort qui est
bouleversant parce que bien sûr on en a
parlé déjà tous les deux
cet après-midi où ça vous les détails
comme ça et puis ce qui est incroyable
c'est justement comme tu disais les
jeunes donnent la leçon aux adultes et
d'ailleurs ils vous reproche de n'avoir
rien fait pour eux donc du coup ils sont
extrêmement violents et vous m'avez
écouté ce que j'ai dit là bon on l'a dit
à 2 secondes
[Rires]
c'est un film brillant ici il y a une
scène qui est forte dans le film c'est
un moment il y a un mec qui vous demande
si qu'est-ce que tu ferais si tu te
barrer du quartier et vous répondez pas
comme si en fait vous étiez condamné à y
rester est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ça
c'est un peu le manque de courage c'est
quand même un manque de courage parce
que on se bloque nous même dans nos en
fait donc on se dit c'est pas possible
c'est impossible et donc c'est vrai
qu'on a du mal à bouger mais après il
faut je pense qu'il faut du courage mais
là sur ce sur ce film oui c'est c'est
vrai que en plus je suis en chaise
roulante donc voilà j'ai pas j'ai pas
très j'ai pas trop les moyens de m'en
sortir mon seul repère c'est mon
quartier mon frère donc c'est pour ça
que je mets à tâche beaucoup j'ai pas
envie qu'il parte donc j'ai vraiment pas
le courage de partir quoi oui Patrick il
y a eu la haine il y a eu les misérables
qui sont des films marquants sur ces
univers là là il y a gravité est-ce que
quand vous tournez dans un film comme ça
vous vous rendez compte que ça va
marquer une génération que c'est un film
vraiment à part quand on est acteur d'un
réalisateur comme ça est-ce que on se
rend compte de la de la puissance du
film
c'est différent Les Misérables
c'est de quoi je parle
c'est différent Les Misérables c'était
vraiment un film relation police jeune
là c'est vraiment un film où on est il y
a pas de police il y a pas de il y a pas
d'armes c'est des c'est des c'est on va
dire c'est des bagarres des grandes
chorégraphies le réalisateur est un peu
son univers c'est le manga donc c'est
vraiment un film d'action d'action qui
se passe dans une cité quoi d'ailleurs
ce qui est intéressant dans le film
c'est que justement il y a c'est
l'absence de la police c'est que c'est
en fait la cité qui est un personnage et
vous les les plus âgés face à des ados
qui sont carrément quasiment nihilistes
et c'est ce ce duel là
intergénérationnel
non mais donc c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est qu'en fait c'est une
sorte d'écosystème et alors avec la
science-fiction par le sucre
il s'appelle la bande des Rona les Ronin
ce sont les samouraïs sans mettre et il
se c'est une culture en train de des
mangas japonais ça y'en a tu comprends
ce qu'ils disent
j'ai compris c'est une illusion des
jeunes tu les as pas trouvé un peu
avec un discours inédit
[Musique]
non mais pour donner aussi envie moi je
voudrais dire que Cédric ido donc le
réalisateur a fait un travail
extraordinaire c'est un film de cinéma
avant tout extraordinaire d'un point de
vue les décors les acteurs la photo la
musique tout est sublime la mise en
scène moi j'ai vraiment j'étais scotché
il va pour moi il va c'est la zone trier
ses chrono Berg c'est vraiment énorme
c'est un grand film de cinéma et vous
êtes exceptionnel effectivement merci
voilà merci j'ai pas posé de questions
on l'adore
[Rires]
un truc mamie mais moi je trouve ça
formidable que en fait on parle beaucoup
des cités des quartiers mais maintenant
on fait du vrai cinéma justement avant
on était presque plus sur le reportage
documentaire et là ce sont des vrais
films il y a le jeune imam dont on a
parlé l'autre jour aussi il y a des
histoires c'est une toile de fond parce
que c'est la réalité mais ça c'est
vraiment du vrai cinéma moi j'ai pris
beaucoup de plaisir à avoir ce film
c'est un grand grand film c'est la haine
2.0 en fait quoi c'est pas un cliché en
plus c'est pas un film cliché c'est ça
évite les clichés exactement
d'une intelligence je trouve le titre
parce que la gravité c'est aussi tout ce
qui retient ses gosses là-bas euh
c'est très inédit avec un double sens le
titre la gravité c'est très inédite
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]